a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo su
cui i ragazzi
tenetevi pronti perché se non conoscete
questo videogame e il che sarebbe grave
preparatevi perché state per vedere uno
dei videogame con più senso della storia
e questo videogame pieno di fargli cose
fantastiche di grafica epica consiste in
correre praticamente ragazzi vi spiego
lo scopo del gioco sarebbe lo vedete
questo tizio comodamente seduto sul
ginocchio ce l'hai ancora la rotula zio
va bene è praticamente ok perfetto ho
fatto meno 0,1 m
praticamente devo dovrei dovrei poi non
lo so se riesco dovrei andare avanti
invece che dalla parte opposta stata un
attimo che devo premere ok ok quanto
sono bravo di 15 ok questo è già un
record per me non lo sapete ma un record
in teoria sta roba consisterebbe ragazzi
nel correre nell'andare avanti
ok 1 1,6 perfetto sono sta andando
avanti di di 0,2 m ogni volta si no
questo caso niente 0,7 sempre ragazzi vi
giuro che come gioco è un casino la
maggior parte di voi lo conoscerà già al
penso niente niente ho battuto la testa
sono vivo la maggior parte di voi penso
che lo conosca già comunque come gioco
per chi non lo conosce può notare che ha
un senso incredibile no sì sì sì sì ok
ok ci siamo no raga non ce l'ha niente
niente impossibile allora sto gioco è
una cosa sì sì addio
io non lo farò mai una cosa del genere
non ci credo un nuovo ok ok ma mai non
farò mai più una cosa non so come ho
fatto non lo so
ok 9,6 è stata incredibile mi sono
emozionato tantissimo
poi bellissimo come corre e fantascienza
i legamenti epico lazio sembra che
veramente abbia preso dei medicinali
poi fa un rumore stranissimo tv non si
sa come e cosa ma quindi sei bravo
ragazzi non ha senso parlare contro kiss
in modo non riesco a fare un metro
approviamo un po di tattiche perché così
non andiamo avanti e nel vero senso
della parola
infatti la digue madonna santissima loro
ok la possiamo fare e non già si fa e
lui il campione e lui sì o che bravo bra
brawn si cammini come se fossi un mondo
plastico ragazzi non sono più che
possibile ragazzi che cazzo sta facendo
mi sembra un anguilla
vabbè comunque mi spiega perchè si muove
come un mondo plastico cioè che cosa
cazzo cia mio dio si può fare più di un
passo con sto tizio impossibile
[Musica]
ok oddio oddio ok ok ho preso ho preso
ritmo ho preso ritmo record record di 10
metri 10 10 10
va benissimo fin che l'atleta va
lasciala [ __ ]
ragazzi è un caso perso studio dio come
cazzo fa ragazzi non so come ci è
arrivato così non vedere
ma perché ti stai mette la mano chi non
ha senso cioè lui corre così non si sa
come mai a darmi la risposta a tutto
questo perché piano piano si si si
riattiva motivo
oddio 12 14 si grande
vabbè sono traguardi che nella vita una
persona sogna di raggiungere gli è
capitata la musa da ragazzi la musica
non è troppo epica quella che parte
quando corri questa qui non ha senso
donna è bello che quando cade si smonta
le rotule toni non si sa che cazzo fa
guardate come cia le gambe sto povero
cristiano non lo so il ginocchio
indietro probabilmente a fine corsa non
ce l'avrà più perderà una gamba
quest'uomo ma non importa l'importante è
la gloria 7 8 metri
ragazzi questa non potevo scoprire la
prima sta tattica e fantastica ci
possiamo arrivare in questa maniera
tatticissima che molto utilizzata anche
nelle olimpiadi oggi ce la possiamo fare
la caccia possiamo fare incredibile
niente ci ferma niente il ginocchio
mobile tutto vai così dai dai ragazzi
non ci credete che così ho fatto più di
prima devo fare devo fare soltanto un
metro ce l'ho fatta vai così mai così un
metro maledizione raga e il credibile è
incredibile
no no no siamo siamo lì siamo pali ma ce
la facciamo
grazie ed è record e dei ragazzi voglio
condividere questo momento fantastico
con tutti voi perché qua c'è allenamento
serio dietro queste cose è il fantastico
io amo questo gioco siamo a 25 metri poi
vai avanti
bravissimo ragazzi che cazzo quello c'è
un ostacolo ma ci manca che ci mettono
gli ostacoli sto cazzo di gioco non ho
niente contro i the matinée rilevare dai
[ __ ] bravissimo ho trovato un nuovo
compagno di giochi raicam i miei mi
sentivo molto solo dopo quattro ore di
camminata quindi effettivamente ci sta
anche ragazzi nel dubbio vendo su ebay
ostacolo olimpionico perché l'ho trovato
per caso vai così 55 fottuti metri di
gioia ciò può fare vado scavalcarlo e
craxi
si no ragazzi dove sarebbe alza il piede
alza il piede come cazzo faccia
liberarmi di un ostacolo del genere
impossibile devi toglierti debito no no
no si no
ok ragazzi siamo siamo molto precari in
questo momento si o no no no ma
[ __ ] perché ho preso al quale
normalmente con era competente ragazzi
che quella era la tattica giusta correre
sbagliato nella vita da adesso in avanti
tutti quando uscite di casa dovette
correre come facevo io prima perché la
gente deve capire che corre normalmente
è sbagliato devi dovete correre così
volevo provarne un altro ragazzi della
stessa casa di prima che ha fatto coopi
che è gip che non ho capito l'aspettate
attimo click to start a dokic allo
schermo ok ci siamo perfetti era già
difficile così strano devo premere i
tasti sulla tastiera cebi che cazzo fa
da sola forse ho capito b ma devo tenere
premuto i tasti so che è una l e questo
è un altro di quei giochi che ha un
senso incredibile adesso devo arrivare
ad m devo lanciarmi di sopra tipo così
oddio 04 quasi crociera o quasi ma ma la
cosa ne acqua sale sempre non capito il
senso di parma dove devo andare avanti
finché non sale l'acqua non sarei qua
come cazzo ho fatto ragazzi va bene così
t adesso la tim
adesso sia aperto google non si sa
perché z ragazzi sto facendo
probabilmente qualche record mondiale
tratto voi non mi state vedendo come
sono messo sulla tastiera ma vi giuro
che cio le mani intrecciati stime invece
la posso fare ora s ragazza stiamo
facendo
ce la stiamo facendo allungati uomo come
allunghi il tuo allungatevi e devi
allungati non devi farlo bazzi e che
cazzo fai ragazzi non ha senso perché il
cazzo c'è un ufficio nel iii sopraffatte
togli toglietelo gli applauditi dai
[ __ ] piccioni di me devo premere la
devo prendere la effe che la mia lettera
la mia lettera fermi f
si ok adesso mi servirebbe latino sto
piccione di meccanici che devi toglierti
bravo
togliti dalle case per chi si deve
mettere in mezzo ai [ __ ] stop venuto
alla emi up [ __ ] togli te che cazzo ti
prendo a calci sto visione del collo
allora sulla pizza non sulla p pezzo di
merda ragazzi devo togliere quel pennuto
togliti dai cazzo a prendere la fine
netto sì come cazzo sommesso come cazzo
sommesso non lo so la jella jamie serve
anche questa è la mia lettera togliti
penelopi a schiaffi s'arriva suo e trova
un fucile ti giuro che finisci male te
lo dico subito ragazzi non ci arrivo non
ci arriva da saltare non ci arriva da
saltare non ci arrivo devo saltare
no no no [ __ ]
ragazzi ci ho provato 16 fottuti metri
di salita che non farò mai più in vita
mia
ragazzi io se trovate senza riuscito a
capire come mai il creatore visto gioco
era così triste ad aver creato sta roba
di the man o comunque ragazzi devilder
piaciuto al commerce rito ha lasciato
argomento mi piace anche l'appoggio di
facebook con i video trovate nella
descrizione sacri scritti iscrivetevi ci
vediamo un prossimo video da ragazzi